like everyone else retailers are being
forced to think outside the box during
the pandemic they're trying to attract
shoppers who may not want to go to the
stores
meg oliver reports on the challenges
facing retail and what was already a
tough environment
stores are dressed up in holiday sparkle
i'm so excited for christmas season
but this season rising cases of covet 19
have taken the shine
off of in-person shopping
an experience far different from the
contact sports scenes in years past
to boost sales retailers are taking
measures to reassure customers it's safe
to shop in their stores
including plexiglas shields increased
cleaning
curbside pickup and shopping
reservations to limit the number of
people
in stores not only are they being
challenged by
the loss of retail sales they're also
being challenged by higher expenses in
operating the stores uncertain times
have forced gift givers to be more
tight-fisted
a new survey finds consumers plan to
spend an average of 691 dollars on
gifting
7 percent less than last year e-commerce
continues to grow
80 percent plan to shop online how much
online shopping are you doing right now
it's okay i'm on a first name basis with
my ups man
there is some hope for small businesses
according to a new study
86 percent of people who plan to go out
and shop will visit local retailers
in an effort to protect their main
streets from becoming boarded up
buildings
for cbs this morning saturday meg oliver
montclair
new jersey it's a big deal thinking
about how people are going to shop this
year
yeah my husband was horrified that i
have the credit card number and the
security code memorized from all the
online shopping yeah
having that done you know
[Laughter]